let it snow let it snow Oh Sun is cold
but the farm is blazing
so baby let it snow let it snow let it
stop oh [ __ ] now I never believed in
Santa Claus growing up it's not an Asian
thing and it sure as hell is not a
Korean thing when I told my dad I
believe this at a closet this is what he
told me you are not my son I remember as
an awkward little Asian kid with the
very limited amount of white friends
that I had at the time telling me about
a story about a large bearded fat white
man that would break into your home on
Jesus's birthday I was young but even
then you couldn't fool me should I wish
a Nicholas would as a kid I would think
about it and that [ __ ] just didn't make
sense you're telling me that every year
a 300-pound man would break into your
home without an invitation and you're
supposed to just be okay with it the
[ __ ] I'll give two shits if you got
gifts don't break it to my home you
weren't invited you don't just bust into
somebody's home without an invitation
you have any idea what could happen to
you thanks for the cookies Khalid yeah
let's cook it for you that's exactly how
we will go down all of you are looking
at me like I'm the crazy person I'm not
the crazy one like Santa Claus just
gonna go to some random thugs home and
break in and nothing's gonna happen that
[ __ ] would die probably the thing that
offended me the most as a kid is the
fact that you would look me in the eye
and tell me that Yokozuna was just gonna
go slide right through a two-inch
chimney huh though not only he brings
gifts he just defies the laws of physics
what's up do you have any idea what
would happen to him oh I know Santa
Claus collies [ __ ] you know in a row
just use the front door [ __ ]
USPS Amazon Prime do it all the time and
by the way is nobody going to address
the fact that Santa Claus is a pervert
yeah said it see nobody questions you
old ass but I don't give a [ __ ] how old
you
dude you ain't sweet check it out let me
ask you this what are the [ __ ] is up
with your theme song listen I'm not a
saying
you sound like a repeat but you will
repeat just say the song and pay
attention to the lyrics he sees you when
you're sleeping he knows he oh wait who
wrote that song yeah that's right our
baby touch of wood yeah damn Jared Fogle
eat fresh
he fresh my ass more like eat fresh baby
dick you're [ __ ] sick oh to be
completely honest with you I'm surprised
you never showed up on an episode of
Chris Hanson's to catch a predator
now inside we have st. Nicholas waiting
for Jimmy but this Christmas Santa Claus
has a crazy surprise
follow me what are you doing here Santa
Claus oh no Jimmy did you know that
Jimmy is 11 year old boy be a Christmas
miracle in this note to Jimmy from the
North Pole you wrote Jimmy I know when
you're sleeping I know when you're awake
PS my dick is in a box
okay get the [ __ ] down my boy we're all
[ __ ] out yeah Merry Christmas
[ __ ] hey what is going on
YouTube that's just a couple thousand
Bob I thought I said without about Santa
Claus that's [ __ ] perfect but just to
let you guys know remember every video
is going to be on Sunday at 12 p.m.
especially next year I might do two or
three videos at the week but that's all
going to be up to me but for sure one
video week Sundays at 12 p.m. make sure
that you guys come in tune in and watch
I miss you [ __ ] hey say hi I
love you Santa Claus don't touch me but
I still want gifts just not in a box no
dick in a box thanks for the cookie we
ship the [ __ ] over there ah thanks
for the cookie the finally a spooky haha
thanks for the cookies Cleve what the
[ __ ] me for you [ __ ] Oh Santa Claus you
lost your mind